[Applaudissements]
non à la guerre cris cet homme au moment
de son arrestation lors d'une
manifestation à Saint-Pétersbourg ils
sont plus de 1300 avoir été arrêtés dans
des rassemblements qui ont suivi
l'annonce de la mobilisation en Russie
de 300 000 réservistes sur un potentiel
militaire de 25 millions de personnes
mon petit ami a reçu une note de
l'intendance militaire pour être
mobilisée de cette femme je suis ici
pour manifester à sa place
nous sommes venus protéger nos amis nos
pères nos frères que le président veut
entraîner dans cette guerre brutale cet
étudiant
on apprend aujourd'hui que plusieurs des
manifestants arrêtés se sont vus imposer
un ordre de conscription pendant leur
détention
l'annonce de la mobilisation a aussi
entraîné une rue et vers les billets
d'avion aller simple pour n'importe quel
destination une information niée par
Moscou c'est complètement exagéré dit le
porte-parole du Kremlin il n'y a pas de
cohue pour quitter le pays c'est de la
fête news des centaines de voitures
faisaient pourtant la file pendant des
heures en pleine nuit à la frontière
avec la Géorgie en direction de la
Finlande aussi le trafic s'est
intensifié pendant la nuit
ceux qui ont pu mettre la main sur un
biais d'avion dont les prix ont explosé
depuis hier sont heureux d'avoir pu
quitter la Russie à temps
bien sûr je suis inquiète il passager en
provenance de Moscou je ne pensais
jamais qu'on se rendrait à la
mobilisation
la guerre est atroce 17 hommes qui vient
d'atterrir à Belgrade c'est normal
d'avoir peur
l'Union européenne dit vouloir que ses
membres s'accordent sur une position
commune face à cette afflux de migrants
russes alors que l'Allemagne a déjà
annoncé être prête à accueillir des
déserteurs ici lise Villeneuve
Radio-Canada Montréal